we are now ready to answer the question
are there fragile regions in the human
genome
he is a Syrian yes and here is the proof
if the random breakage model is correct
then an rearrangements apply to circular
chromosome will produce approximately 2n
synteny blocks and therefore since there
are 280 human Mouse synteny blocks the
must be have been approximately 280 over
2 which is 142 breaks on the human mouse
evolutionary path but we have just
learned from the to brake distance area
that there are at least 245 two breaks
on this pass my next question is 245
equal to 140 it turns out that 245 is
much larger than 140 even if you apply
rigorous statistic allowing for some
differences between these two number
which means that we arrive at the
contradiction
implying that one of our assumptions in
the course of proving this area is
incorrect but which one well there is
not much choice because we have made
only one assumption here it is if the
random breakage model is correct and
since the based on this assumption we
arrived to a contradiction it means that
our assumption was incorrect which
implies the random breakage model failed
well the demonstrated the random
breakage model is incorrect but of
course we have not provided you visas
allocation of fragile regions in the
human genome and it is an example of
non-constructive proof when we prove
that something is wrong but cannot
provide a certificate showing where the
fragile regions allocated but if the
random breakage model is incorrect how
would you explain the remarkable feat
between ZUP
your plans of synteny blocks and the
exponential distribution well why have
biologists embrace random breakage model
actually it was a logical fallacy RBM
random breakage model is not the only
model that complies with is exponential
distribution test so it is correct to
claim that random breakage model implies
exponential distribution but it is
absolutely incorrect to claim that
exponential distribution implies the
random breakage model
so why was random breakage model refuted
because it doesn't comply with observed
breakpoint reuse and the question is is
a model that compliance with these both
the exponential distribution and the
breakpoint reuse phenomena and it turn
out that so-called fragile breakage
model indeed explain both phenomena
according to the fragile breakage model
our genomes represent a mosaic of
fragile regions with this high
propensity for arrangements and solid
region that hardly ever broken by region
and fragile regions which means regions
between consecutive synteny blocks are
short counting let's say in the case of
human genome for less than 5% of our
genomes now the question of course is
rise how FBM for fragile breakage model
explained both exponential distribution
and the rearrangement hotspot well a
small number of short fragile regions
explain rearrangement hotspot because
there are very few regions where
rearrangements actually can happen
therefore they are bound to be repeated
in the same places also if so agile
regions are somewhat randomly
distributed throughout the genome then
the synteny blocks lands follow exactly
the same exponential distribution as in
the case of the random breakage model
and therefore a fragile breakage model
it
explain Bohr's exponential distribution
and breakpoint rules and should be used
as a substitute for the random breakage
model but maybe a fragile breakage model
uses the same logical fallacies as the
random breakage model users because
maybe there is a test that was random
breakage model and fragile breakage
model fail it turned out very recently
that indeed there is such a test and
this test became possible because many
genomes have been sequenced in recent
years and scientists were able to
analyze breakpoints not only between two
genomes human and mouse the first
segment genome but between multiply gems
and they proposed so-called multiply
breakpoint reuse test which analyzes
breakpoints all cross-multiply genomes
unfortunately we don't have time to go
into the details of the multiply
breakpoint reuse test but I can only
tell you what follows from studies that
analyzed this test this recent study
revealed evidence for births and deaths
of the fragile regions which means that
fragile regions exist but they are not
static they move to different locations
in human and mouse genome and the
positions of the fragile region in human
genome are different than the positions
of the fragile regions in Mouse and this
discovery resulted in the turnover
fragile breakage model which allows for
changes in the location of fragile
regions and this new fragile
turnover fragile breakage model actually
compliance it is a new multiply
breakpoint reuse test moreover it
actually points to the location of the
currently fragile regions the questions
that V they are not able to answer when
we were proving the last cerium from the
last section so eternal fragile breakage
model actually compliance with all three
tests does it mean that it
absolutely final model for Ramazan
evolution of course not there is a
possibility that future studies will
reveal new in new tests and will lead to
further development of the owl of our
views of chromosome evolution and this
turnover fragile breakage model
developed there are still questions that
remains to be answered
where are the fragile regions located
and what causes fragility and
availability of multiplied genomes will
help us eventually to answer this
question and to figure out what are the
currently active fragile regions in the
human genome what will be maybe the next
reversals that happen in the human
genome let's say the next million years
and now after we covered different
algorithmic aspect of genome
rearrangements the time has come to
answer one of the first questions that
appeared in this lesson is how to
generate synteny blocks starting from
long genomes